Why do Voices Squeak During Puberty?
Once you activate your vocal system, the air
in your lungs gets pushed up by the relaxation
of your diaphragm.
It then goes through your trachea and out
a small orifice that has two folds of skin
(vocal cords) on either side of it, in the
shape of a V; this is called your larynx,
or voice box.
As the muscles that attach to your voice box
tense and relax, they create a vibration of
the cords.
As these cords vibrate, they release pulses
of air.
The tension in these muscles creates the differences
in frequency, the higher the tension, the
higher the frequency and, therefore, the higher
the pitch.
This frequency is measured in hertz (how many
times a second this repeats).
For example, typical vibrations from speech
usually range from approx.
200 hertz-8,000 hertz.
When we are kids, our larynx is relatively
small and our vocal cords are relatively thin.
Think of guitar strings, the smaller and thinner
the string, the higher the pitch.
As boys go through puberty, the increasing
amounts of testosterone leads to a lengthening
of the cartilage of the larynx and a thickening
of the vocal folds.
This lengthening and thickening deepens the
tone in their voices, similar to the effect
of lengthening and thickening a guitar string.
Along with the “guitar strings” of the
voice box getting bigger, there are also other
features affecting the sound of one’s voice
that are changing.
For instance, things like the nose, back of
the throat (hypopharnyx), sinuses and facial
bones getting bigger will affect the ultimate
sound of the voice.
These bigger features create more space in
your facial area, giving your vocal sounds
more room to resonate.
The changes to the voice box generally take
place gradually over a period of time.
Sometimes, however, when there is a dramatic
period of change, the body has not “grown
into” its newly sized cords and vocal mechanism
and has trouble adjusting, in terms of being
able to make steady sounds.
So the sudden and differing growth rates of
everything involved in making sounds causes
the brain to sometimes have a hard time controlling
the voice mechanism to maintain a steady vibrating
resonance.
As a result of this, poor little Billy must
endure his voice cracking from time to time
while his brain adjusts to the quick changes
his body is going through.